where were you emotionally and what
happened when you heard that the film
may or may not happen
oh it was definitely over the years as a
roller coaster i've had some of those
other
some other experiences like that where
films were you know
on the verge i it was it was
it was always teetering on that line of
willard or won it for a while
and um i think i became
so and again it wasn't it really just
had to do with the
lining up the money it wasn't that i
i was i didn't think that you know micah
chris was
enthusiastic i just thought it just came
down to dollars and cents
and you know
uh so but i became very just um
sort of uh immune to the the roller
coaster of emotions and just
sort of accepted everything as it was
and
just you know was optimistic that it
eventually would happen it was just a
matter of timing like everything else
is that something that you practiced
early on or
you learn to develop i just it's comes
with age
and maturation and and my martial arts
training
you know i again i'm i'm an impatient
person by nature
but i've definitely tempered it learned
to temper it over the years and just
keep everything in perspective
and there's just so many things that are
out of your control i tell that to my
wife all the time
it was like with you know with any
aspect of life
um and filmmaking obviously is no
different
you just it requires such a tremendous
amount of patience look i have a film
another film now
that i've been sitting on for four years
which i think is a
you know very timely concept
with everything we're going through it
was timely four years ago
um but
trying to get everybody in sync with
everyone's schedule and i don't blame
anyone
everyone's got their own thing they're
doing but
it it definitely gets to the point and
i'm still guilty of being
of being like you know what in the
effort we doing what's going on here
um it can be very it can be very just
you you really have to learn to
you know i would say you know if it's if
it's a year
that's one thing but we're you know when
you go on three four years and you're
still waiting it's like
okay you start to get a little like
you start to get you know a little uh
wary about where everything is and
you know just hope that again
your number's called but again so many
things are out of your control and again
that was a teacher at
nyu that said if you stick with it
eventually
that was my manager your manager if you
if you keep if you keep at it you know
eventually your number comes up
i learned that about i learned that
about my wife you know i i was single
for many years
um and
i would get frustrated that i was like
you know i just like to meet a nice girl
um and uh
somebody who i i really felt that
connection with
and it took a long time but you know
eventually my number got called and
we've been you know actually we just
uh we've been together four years of as
of yesterday and oh great
we met four years ago yesterday and then
uh we've been married for
close to two years congratulations you
know thank you very much
um but it it just
i think it i think it's just um look
some people have it sooner
other people it happens a little bit
later and you just
i think if you can just stay optimistic
and stay focused and and
keep moving forward and not get
discouraged and it's so hard to get
discouraged
it's so hard um
but i really believe that if it's you're
truly passionate about it
and at the same time you have you have
that talent and you have a story
multiple great stories to tell but just
take one just takes one
it'll it'll eventually it will
eventually
get you there i do believe that i'm
living proof of that
but again it's it's not getting
discouraged so many people
actors writers directors everyone comes
to how hollywood is
is is is meant to discourage you
it's here to discourage you it's it's
the you know development
development people are are paid to say
no
they're paid to say no to to writers
so you know
and it's so easy to just get discouraged
and turned off by that
and we all have dealt with it but i will
say that
you know if if if you
stick to your guns you
keep honing your craft you
stay encouraged not discouraged
and you keep marching forward sorry for
for you know the cliches but it's true
um and you have and you do have a talent
for it
even a modicum of talent if you have it
and you keep
nurturing it you know
and you and again eventually you know i
do i do think i i think it was um
i do think it was aaron stork and i
believe who said um
you know good material eventually finds
its way
i believe it was him it sounds like
i watched the master class with him it
was excellent i feel like you might have
said that as well
and in a sense not not to cheapen dating
with with the film industry
but there's some similarities in that in
la the dating world is so much about
oh how do they look on paper absolutely
where'd they go to school what are how
are they looking for what
what's this oh yeah sometimes people
don't even care about that they just
want to know what do they do for a
living yeah
absolutely and so that equates the same
way in the film industry who's attached
what what is this
and it's like the same i need something
bigger i need this i need better
but then that one special thing i.e or
the special person
you can somehow find that but it takes a
long time i think
yeah it it sometimes can sometimes it's
quick sometimes it's
you know it doesn't take as long
sometimes it takes longer
um and again you know i'm not saying
look
i mean people may read the read take
back or watch take back eventually be
like you know what
but you know we've all
seen those movies we're like what were
they thinking you know how did this
thing get made i'm guilty of saying that
i am but
i still think that there has to be a
couple of things the
the the the script has to be somewhat
decent
all right it has to be legible it has to
have some kind of emotion tied into it
and again you don't know how how
it could just affect and somebody reacts
luckily you know christian mike
both really liked the script they dug it
and they were like okay we're
let's let's get rocking on this the
producer who took it to them
was the same way like they took to it
and again
i had a number of people who are lined
up who did
really like the script and and were high
on it so that was
i had that going for me um but sometimes
look it it may
again bring you back to the french
connection i think that went to 25
different places
before somebody said yes really yeah
i believe don't quote me but i believe
it went to every studio in town
production companies it went all around
and there's a handful of other
screenplays that went around
you know it it was and it wasn't like
you know
the the a bidding war for them
and you know you saw and you saw what
what what
amazing movies came out of that and
again i'm not saying ours is going to be
on that level
but all it takes is one person to say
yes
20 people may say no 25 in the case of
french connection say 24 said no and
then
i believe it was um um
oh uh z-zanik i believe was oh okay
dick zanuck said yes when he was running
things over there he was young he was
the wonderkind
and his father daryl had run fox and he
said yes
it's it's um that's it
and if you're and i was fortunate that
that happened and i hope it happens
again
i believe you said you've been writing
scripts ever since you were at nyu
yeah how many years did you go
even though 20 okay i optioned
i did option a number of scripts along
the way
[Music]
and iowa again i had i was fortunate
that some of my scripts served as good
samples to get me into meetings with
a number of you know uh fairly
well-known producers and network execs
but this was the first group that i was
able to really close
it took a while 20 years 20 years
20 years and um you know i'm i'm
grateful that it
you know that it's here i'm grateful
that i do have the credit um
but it did take a while um and you know
again i'm
i'm one of those and i'm sure many guys
and girls who who had
had a lot of near misses with their
scripts no doubt
no and and i and i was fortunate that a
lot of those people really did like my
work that i submitted
it was always like we really like your
script not this but what else do you
have and i'd say well i have this and
they're like yeah and it just didn't
always sync up
you know i did i did have some really
wonderful meetings with some
you know again some fairly well-known
people but
in the end it just uh yeah
it this this this happened finally it
was wonderful
well we always hear about you know 20
under 25 and and you know if you look at
was it steve larsen
from the the trilogy series the girl
with the dragon tattoo yeah
i think he was almost 50 i know he's 50
when he passed away but yeah he'd been
working on
at least one book i'm not sure yeah what
he died i think
they came out after he died he never
even saw the success
right and he had been a journalist and
doing other things and and so
it took a very long time but he was just
very dedicated to
he wanted to do it right yeah there was
a gentleman who just um
uh i believe sold he was i think he's in
his 40s
and he had something similar happen uh
where he was like just living
hand-to-mouth he had a family
i believe he's maybe even irish and i
think he sold
a he wrote a book that sold for a few
million dollars
oh wow and he yeah um
there definitely have been yeah there
there are and i
i certainly don't you know i
i i try to stay young so i don't feel my
age
uh but no it was it was just definitely
you know just just sticking just staying
on the path and and sticking with it
and you know um
[Music]
again you know this isn't like you know
a major studio film
but it's still i i'm i'm proud of where
what happened with it i'm proud that it
got made it's not easy and especially
during the time of kovitz so i
definitely take some pride in that
um and if it leads to
great things you know that would be
wonderful um
but i definitely did feel a sense of
accomplishment when you know i got that
paycheck and
you know it's you know the cameras were
rolling it really felt great
it really felt great um and again i hope
to
continue writing you know and
you know uh having other stuff produced
we'll see it remains to be seen
at what point in the 20 years did you
say i'm not giving up i would say
you know again i i was i was repped i
did have a literary manager for a long
time
um who got my work out there and
i felt like over the years we got close
on a few things and it was you know it
was obviously like a tease
um so i never really felt like
you know i was i was ready to give up i
always knew that i i just have a passion
of burning passion to write so i
in my mind i was like look i'm gonna
keep doing this um
and i will get there um you know
i did have some very supportive people
not certainly not
um ass kissers telling me you know just
keep going
um and it was encouraging um and i think
really once i got this script and the
other script that i
mentioned that's sort of uh with
attachments i think once those started
coming in the last few years that was
like okay
it started feeling like okay this will
eventually happen it
there we're gonna go through we
obviously went through some discouraging
times in a little bit of the emotional
rollercoaster
but we were we were able to i felt
eventually we were gonna
we were gonna get there so um i'd say in
the last few years
i also i also started um
[Music]
about five years ago i started writing
novels as well
and i have a i do have a agent a book
agent
um and he's always been very encouraging
and you know he's
he has one of our books that he's
shopping now at a lot of the major
publishers
um uh so
you know it's it's i feel encouraged by
that as well
um but yeah i never i never really
i of course there were there are moments
like am i gonna am i gonna quit
do i did i get discouraged yes but i
never felt like i was gonna quit
what did the script sale teach you
humility perseverance
um
yeah it's uh
when i when i saw that when i saw the
the uh it was actually deposit
um don't tell my account um
you know i got a little misty-eyed but i
think
i had been through so much with the you
know again
over the years the you know just
again people liking your work you're
thinking you were close to something but
it was when it was
it was i hate to say anti-climactic
and i got a little misty-eyed but i was
like okay
this is great but i i think i'd been
i had been at it so long that i was like
you know just
it was it was um it was definitely a uh
um i definitely was humbled i was i
definitely felt
humbled by it i really did
humbled in the sense that you stuck with
it because
you loved it or humbled in the sense
that your number was
both yeah i did
i felt um
know again it was just the it was it was
a lot of years
and you know it's
um i you know the funny thing is the
thing that went to me is like oh well
maybe this also could be the last time
but i did it i did it
and that was great that was that was
you know what i took from it i savored
it
um but i just i just
i guess my i wasn't like i jumped down
up and down of this you know around the
house and popped the champagne cork
as much as i had always envisioned that
right for years like
you know i'm gonna go you know ape crap
here and and just
you know do cartwheels down the street
risky business right exactly
exactly yeah take my
take my neighbor's porsche
no it wasn't it wasn't it wasn't really
like that at all it was
again just anticlimactic in a lot of
regards but again i still left feeling
very
just humbled by the time in the
experience and
you know and feeling that perseverance
that okay
this is real i i made it here and
so if it's the only thing that i ever do
i still i still have it on i still have
it
you know i still have a credit i still
have it there and that was wonderful
and i hope there's i hope there are more
we'll see
that was my next question how confident
are you that you will get another movie
made
well i
feel that the other film
[Music]
other script that i have is you know
again timely
i i feel very connected to it i
i think that it's it's got some really
terrific elements in it
um but
it comes down to dollars and cents and
if the money's there i think we're in
good shape um
i you know it's it's also just always
gauging people's levels of commitment
in these things and i i feel like
they are committed um but um
yeah i think it comes down to attaching
people and
and and and getting everyone working
i think it's gelling everyone together
in order to
to push it through that's what i that's
what i'm hoping
but at this point yeah it's a matter of
getting
getting the the investment
into it you know that one and a half to
three mil
it'll take to to get there and then
hopefully it's it leads to
you know snapping the clap
soon sooner rather than later but we'll
see
so going back to that question i had
said about if you were
going to teach someone to write a
screenplay that sells
the first question probably would be why
do you even want to do it in the first
place because that same person
may not stick with that absolutely for
the 20 years but if you love it
yeah if it if it's a burning passion and
it gets you up in the morning and
um you just enjoy the process and
you know the highs and lows that come
with it
then go for it if it's something where
you know there's nothing wrong with
giving it a try but if it's something
where you're not really it's like
anything else it's
it's what it's a it's malcolm gladwell's
a 10 000 hour rule right where
you you know you put in your ten
thousand hours i don't
see you become an expert but you become
pretty proficient at something
it's just like that um but i think also
with that
ten thousand hours you really have to
love doing it
it really has to get you going and
you know you you really it's it's
essentially it is like
uh your mistress
it's my mistress now was my girlfriend
for many years she became my mission
running became my mistress after i got
married and my wife
you know my wife coexists with her
pretty well but
[Laughter]
but yeah it's definitely something you
just have to have an unbridled passion
for
and and you seek to get up every morning
and it it's there and you it's like
and it's like going to the gym and
working out
it's working your riding muscles every
day just going to the gym going to the
writing gym
so the goldfinch donna tartt take her 12
years
to finish that did it maybe it's is it a
sequel so another
she had another one there i think both
turned into films i know the name
goldfinch was turned into a film but if
i uh maybe
but yeah 12 years yeah that's dedication
and she just loved she loved the process
absolutely i mean you know there's uh
you know i think
william goldman he was he was younger
when he because he was a novelist when
he was a stat he established himself
probably in his late 20s 30
ish as a but i don't think his first
film was made until he was maybe in his
mid
30s um
so yeah there's there's definitely maybe
he's not the best example but
there's definitely you know i feel like
writers or
artists or etc out there who are
you know sometimes it just takes them a
little longer to gestate and
find find the story that that is gonna
they're gonna
you know make their mark with or or at
least break through
with that piece of work
did you write every day for 20 years
almost
i would say close to it not i there were
times obviously
some weekends um or when i had my
daughter
it wasn't always the easiest thing but
there were times where i'd get up early
before she was awake and especially when
she was
a baby um super early and and work
now she sleeps late so uh but no i
i usually i at this at this stage uh
there
occasionally i work on the weekends but
generally i confine it to monday through
friday
for the most part so that 20 years you
would get up at
quarter to six not every day but i would
i would make
i would make it and then you know i was
working when i was working i
i worked at fox again as a research
analyst for a number of years i would
use you know i'd be up early before
i'd have to work um and then i usually
work during my lunch break
so i tried always try to get in at least
maybe like three hours um
you know and then i would i would work
sometimes on the weekend definitely
before i was married
um but now i feel like you know um
i feel like i'm getting hitting most of
my goals during the week
again working smarter not harder
you